good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster today the former
prime minister david cameron says he
will respond
positively to any investigation into his
links
with the financier lex greenself and as
surge testing begins in a
third london borough after the south
african variant was detected there
a suggestion that airborne transmission
needs to be monitored more closely
to stem the spread of coronavirus more
and all of that
in just a moment also today how to make
sure you're still in the driving seat
when you're working from home
we'll talk to the woman who recreated
the office environment from the limited
comfort
of her car that's at 8 40. and also for
you
45 packages today we've got three hours
to deliver them
with a cheeky snippet of my song in
between each one i'm sure we can manage
at 850 a different type of gig economy
we'll talk to the musician who delivered
a song as well as amazon parcels
in an effort to promote his new single
it's thursday
the 15th of april under scrutiny
david cameron says he will respond
positively to inquiries into his
connections to the
lex greensville capital issue
airing their concerns doctors say pubs
and restaurants
must improve ventilation as they warn
more should be done to prevent the
airborne transmission of kobit 19.
the civilian ceremony the report
suggests none of the royal family will
wear military uniforms
at the funeral of the duke of edinburgh
on saturday
protest for a fourth night in
minneapolis after a police officer is
charged with the killing of an
unarmed black man just a few miles from
where
george floyd died making these women
visible
sky news meets the illustrator painting
portraits
of the 118 women killed by men in the uk
over the last year
good morning high pressure dominating
our weather for the next few days so
plenty of sunshine to come
but it remains rather chilly so
gardeners take note frosty nights
a very good morning to you david cameron
says he will respond positively to
any investigation into his links with a
financier lex green sill
the former prime minister is accused of
lobbying ministers on behalf of green
sill
when it was trying to access government
covered loans now the company
subsequently collapsed
leaving thousands of jobs under threat a
spokesman for mr cameron said he was
keen
that lessons are learned but let's talk
to our political correspondent rob
powell
who's here finally getting some more
comment from david cameron as the
pressure from labor
to really look into this is is
continuing to pile up yeah and while
that broader inquiry that labour were
calling for yesterday while that didn't
get through while that was blocked by
tory votes
actually it may not matter because there
are already a number of investigations
that will be going on there's this
lawyer-led review commissioned by boris
johnson
but then at least two committees of mps
so the cross-party groups
that scrutinize government but also look
into other issues as well they've
indicated that they will be
looking into this so i think there'll be
ample opportunity for david cameron to
come
and give his side of the story albeit
some of these
committee investigations look at the
more technical side in terms of
green sale capital and why it went into
administration that's the firm obviously
that david cameron
was working for it'll also look at the
type of supply chain
finance uh that david cameron you can
see there with lex greensill
who ran that business the type of
financing that they um did but no doubt
it will touch on his interactions with
ministers and lobbying as well now
overnight david cameron spokesperson
has put out a statement on his behalf in
which they've said david cameron will
respond positively to all such requests
when the terms
of reference of each inquiry are made
clear and any invitations to provide
evidence
are received while he was an advisor to
the business and not a board director
he's keen to ensure that lessons from it
going into administration
are learned i think the mps as well as
looking at the lessons
learned from it going bust probably will
be equally keen to learn some lessons
from david cameron's interactions with
ministers
i think this will go broader than just
the political aspect of this as well
this is also now roped in civil servants
the non-political aspects of government
uh with
after those revelations that one civil
servant had a paid advisory role at
green sill
while working on whitehall the daily
telegraph has similar revelations this
morning
and later this morning we'll also hear
from lord pickles eric pickles
former conservative minister known for
uh plain speaking frankly he's now the
chair of acoba lots of acronyms and all
this
that basically scrutinizes business
appointments for cabinet for ministers
and officials lots of criticisms that
that body he chairs
just doesn't have enough power i think
it'll be very interesting to see whether
he thinks the rules now need to change
okay rob thank you now
surge testing is beginning in a third
london borough this morning after the
south african variant was detected there
from today people who live in the n3
postcode of finchley
or who pass through the area will be
asked to get tested now surge testing
for the new variant
has already started in three boroughs of
south
london wandsworth lamberth and southwark
okay let's talk to hanisha sethi who's
outside one of the testing centers
in north london and it we're only
thinking that
current there's only sort of one case
been detected there but
still that's enough to cause this level
of concern
exactly well and this is yet another
area
of london that will undergo surge
testing because the south african
variant of covert 19
has been detected here and the postcode
that will undergo surge
testing is n3 so if you live work or
travel through this postcode it is
required or you are encouraged
to take a test but officials will be
setting up at around
8am in finchley central station
car park so it is encouraged that you
come down we are expecting a few queues
this morning as well
but officials will also be going door to
door handing out
pcr kits as well so if you are at home
it will be encouraged to take a test
there as well
but monday of course since lockdown has
been easing it has been a very busy time
in the uk but especially in barnets
where people have been
um going shopping especially on the high
street of barnet as well so the
government and the local council have
said that
if you have been shopping on the local
high street that's one of the places
where
the virus is easily transmissible in
congested areas
and you must be encouraged to take a
test as well but
um we know that surge testing as you
mentioned earlier has taken place in
wandsworth
and lambeth as well and it's been um
about a few thousand people have taken
um the test
the local council has called it a
mammoth task because of the volume of
people
that need to be tested but it is
encouraged to ensure that
the virus is contained and it doesn't
spread to other boroughs
okay hennessey thank you well let's have
a look at the uk's daily covered figures
and 2
491 new cases of coronavirus have been
reported
with 38 more deaths that brings the
total number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test
to 127 thousand one hundred and sixty
one
another seventy six thousand one hundred
and twenty three people received their
first vaccine
three hundred and twelve thousand six
hundred and eighty five have had their
second dose
that means nearly 40.5
million jabs have been given out across
the uk
now doctors say pubs and restaurants
must improve ventilation as they warn
that more must be done to prevent the
airborne transmission
of kovid19 a new study in the medical
journal the bmj
suggests that efforts to stop covid
should focus on tackling
close airborne transmission rather than
contact
with surfaces well let's talk to dr
julian tang who's clinical virologist at
the university of leicester who wrote
that bmj report good to see you this
morning look there's been so much focus
to date
on hand washing hand sanitizing all
those sort of issues
have we been getting it wrong
hi morning so i would say you're getting
it wrong but i think the emphasis
is wrong so the message hands face space
we think should be really space face
hands
the way the way this virus transmits
sorry that's my computer uh the way this
virus transmits is really through
conversational distance uh like within
one meter
when you're talking to a friend or
sharing the same as you're listening to
your friend talking
we call it the garlic breath distance so
you can smell your friend's lunch or
inhaling some of that air as well as any
virus that's inhaled with it
and this is why we say that masking is
is fine social discipline is fine but
the
indoor airborne environment needs to be
improved
and that can be done with ventilation
and that will also improve things like
you know the common cause each
season as well as you know airborne
pollution and contaminants like a
sick building syndrome and allergens
like pollen that cause hay fever
and work absenteeism every year well
look i mean that
there's been so much the reason it
sounds a bit surprising is there's been
so much sort of questioning
over the last year as to whether masks
were even necessary a lot of people
very against that i mean from from the
evidence you're putting forward it would
seem masks are the absolute fundamental
first step in tackling this
yes and we've seen this in southeast
asia where they had saw 2003 and
even flew and other scares they started
universal masking from the very
beginning
back in january you see places like hong
kong taiwan vietnam
uh thailand and japan to some extent
have been doing really well in this
pandemic without
massive case numbers and deaths and
economic fallout we've been seeing in
the western countries where this wasn't
practiced
now i think the western countries are
more experienced with this they're more
aware of this
and that that distance that kind of
within one meter conversational distance
is where all the danger is
and if you think about it when you talk
to people in the street or in corridors
or just in
over coffee you don't touch the same
surfaces they touch you don't touch each
other
uh when you take a swab the viral load
is you know 10 million to 100 million
viruses in the swab
of course when you breathe it out that
you breathe out less viruses in the swab
but you still be that ten thousand
uh to a thousand viruses per breath and
if you're in that distance
with that one meter distance you can
smell their breath what they had for
lunch
you're hanging the virus as well in
terms of
of what we do then as we look towards
moving things
inside from from next month
um how concerned are you that i mean do
you think places like
pubs and entertainment venues whatever
it might be are in a position
to to let people inside in a safe way in
your view
yeah so in summer months where it's
warmer we did this
some of this last year as well if you
open windows and keep doors open you can
improve that ventilation naturally
and if you think about it you burn your
toast in the kitchen if you open the
windows and the door the back door
it clears very quickly so if you keep
the windows open you know even halfway
most of the time
then you can improve that ventilation
rate in an indoor area
and that reduce the overall airborne
concentration
that you can actually then reduce the
risk of transmission
from so i think this this is really a
kind of
addition to what people are doing the
social distancing the masking
if you're indoors having a drink or
eating you can't mask
you can't maintain social distance so
the ventilation becomes much more
important proportionally
if you're indoors in an indoor space
does this
follow on then or at least tie in with
the prime minister was saying earlier in
the week that he thought
you know the the huge drop we've had in
infections which has been you know very
positive he was saying he thought that
was linked to lockdown rather than
the vaccine rollout does that tie in
with
with
your evidence then with just the the the
reduced contact is making a bigger
difference in vaccination
yes so at the moment the lockdown's the
main is causing the main impact in the
reduction of number of
cases and deaths and the vacuum rollout
is is uh
very rapid and encouraging but we'll see
that impact
once you start to open up indoor spaces
and if one and two people have
antibodies
that immune barrier will reduce that
spread of the virus in an indoor
environment where
you know ventilation is poorer and where
people are closer together unmasked
and and talking breathing the same air
so i think that the prime minister is
correct in that that respect
i mean but you see it almost seems and i
know you're not a
a doom merchant as it were we've talked
many times before but it
it does it does seem quite a dispiriting
sort of message in the sense that all
these
businesses desperate to sort of get back
to normal desperate to restart the
economy
you seem to be saying at least for many
months to come there are going to have
to be some pretty severe restrictions
because of the airborne nature of this
yes but we've been doing that most of
the year already the social distancing
at least the attempt to maintain social
distance in supermarkets the masking
supermarkets
improving the ventilation is not an
overnight thing and a lot of places you
can't open the windows or keep the doors
open
you know easily because of security
issues but if the concept is there if
the
kind of will is there to improve
ventilation over time
those improvements will come in
gradually and that's what we expect
improving infrastructure in buildings is
a very difficult thing and it costs
money but if you look at the cost
benefit over time and this device will
become seasonal
over many years and not everybody will
take the vaccine not everybody will
respond to the vaccine and there'll be
new variants appearing all the time that
escape the vaccines
this is a kind of backup to all
everything else we're doing to maintain
that
that degree of safety that we're all
looking for
okay julian tang it's good to talk to
you thank you
thank you now still to come this morning
at 22 8 we're going to hear from
hospitality uk about how pubs and
restaurants in england have fared so far
since reopening on monday and what will
they need to do
to ensure the spread of coronavirus is
limited we'll mention to her about what
dr tang is saying about extra
ventilation in venues
at quarter to eight i'll talk to the
labour mp jess phillips
about the campaign to remember the lives
of women killed by
men through a series of commemorative
portraits
and at five past eight we're talking to
sir john bell from the uk's vaccines
task force to discuss the latest with
vaccine safety
and the ongoing rollout
now the us climate envoy john kerry has
arrived in china on his visit to discuss
international efforts to tackle climate
change despite the tense relationship
between the countries at the moment
it comes ahead of president biden
hosting a climate summit next week and
the cop 26 conference here in the uk
in november laura correspondent tom
cheshire
joins us now and do we expect any
progress to be made
by mr kerry's visit because we know that
china has got a very long way to go when
it comes to tackling climate issues
yeah we don't know exactly what's going
to be on the table down
in shanghai the fact this visit is
happening first of all is very
interesting by itself
the relations are incredibly bad between
china and the us at the moment
but the biden administration has said
all the way from the beginning that it's
willing to cooperate with china
on climate change it sees that as
separate from other issues that are
causing a lot of friction like taiwan
like xinjiang
like hong kong it wants to talk about
climate change without that being
conditional
china has hinted it might want to sit as
more tighter as it wants to see progress
on other issues before it talks about
climate change
we'll find out more about that as you
say china is the biggest
emitter in the world so there is a lot
to do but it does know it has
a problem i'm here in ningxia in north
west china
and you know it doesn't look like much
really here but what this is
is really the biggest ecological
migration project in the world this
village has been built
to take people from other parts of this
province where there isn't enough water
supply where there's a lot of drought
and move them here because they are
feeling the effects of climate change
already
so they do know there's a problem they
are taking these sort of localized
solutions but the big question really
for china
is about its use of coal it keeps adding
coal power stations incredibly dirty
source of fuel
we've seen that a lot as part of its
post covid recovery
focusing on heavy industry until china
gets off coal
uh we're going to still have a very big
problem in terms of emissions i think
that's going to be one of the issues
very much
on the table when john kerry goes to
shanghai and meets with his counterparts
the question is of course what china
will ask of the us in return
okay tom thank you well just a reminder
that you can keep up to stories like
this
on our daily climate show here on sky
news it's every week day
at half past six and a half past nine
okay let's have a look at some of the
other stories making news for you today
and newspapers report newspaper reports
today
suggest members of the royal family will
not be wearing military uniform at the
duke of edinburgh's funeral
it's understood the queen decided that
senior royals attending the service on
saturday
should be in civilian clothing it means
prince harry
and prince andrew who both stepped down
from royal duties
will not have to face being the only
family members not in uniform
and sky news will have full coverage of
prince philip's funeral
throughout the day on saturday with a
special programme starting
at half past 12. there'll also be live
coverage on sky one
from quarter to three
now there have been more protests in
minnesota overnight but
without the levels of violence seen in
recent days hundreds of people
again took to the streets to protest
about the shooting dead
of twenty-year-old danto wright by a
police officer
the officer involved has now been
charged with second-degree manslaughter
meanwhile just a few miles away the
trial of derek shoving continues the
former officer charged with
george floyd's murder our u.s
correspondent sally lockwood reports now
from minneapolis
[Applause]
a fourth night of unrest in a city on
edge
seeking justice for george floyd and now
seething
at another death at the hands of police
the shooting of dante wright would have
caused outrage regardless
but it couldn't have come at a worse
time for this community
they bring a lot of hate to this world
and it has nothing to do with you or you
but it's just that
how do we stand up without
hurting you or you twenty-year-old dante
wright was shot
during a routine traffic stop on sunday
the police were quick to release body
cam footage
showing the moment they claimed the
officer shot him by
accident and three days later officer
kim potter has been charged with
second-degree manslaughter
a much faster response than after the
death of george floyd
but many here feel nothing's changed
there's no way you could mistake a taser
for a gun
not if you've been on the field for 26
years i can't see that tonight
especially if you're a veteran police
yeah it's
not okay the decision to charge officer
kim potter so quickly
is undoubtedly a bid to try and calm
this community
but many here are still unhappy that she
resigned instead of being fired
and many simply don't buy the police
explanation
that she fired her handgun instead of
her taser by accident
it's added to tension here amid the
trial of former officer derek chauvin
for the death of george floyd
the defense continues to present its
case arguing his restraint of mr floyd
was an appropriate use of force
with a former medical examiner
testifying exhaust fumes drugs
and a heart condition caused his death
mr floyd had a
sudden cardiac arrhythmia or cardiac
arrhythmia
due to his atherosclerotic and
hypertensive
heart disease he would have the
toxicology the fentanyl
and methamphetamine
there is exposure to a vehicle exhaust
all of those combined to
cause mr floyd's death even before a
verdict for the death of george floyd
an all too familiar story has begun
again here
another intersection another death
another shrine
the same city sally lockwood sky news
minneapolis
more than 80 british universities have
been flagged on a website for students
who share
incidents of sexual abuse and harassment
some of the uk's top institutions
including oxford and exeter have been
mentioned
more than 50 times on everyone's invited
to highlight allegations of rape culture
denmark has become the first country to
stop using the oxford astrozetica
vaccine altogether because of concerns
about blood clots
astrazeneca said it respected denmark's
choice
the uk medicines regulator continues to
say the benefits of the vaccine
outweigh any risks
a new study suggests the psychedelic
compound found in magic mushrooms may be
at least as effective as leading
antidepressants
in treating depression psilocybin which
is found in the mushrooms was compared
with a six-week course
of the drug escape telepram
and reductions in depression scores
happened
quicker quicker in the psilocybin group
and in greater magnitude
now if you're a fan of all-out politics
this may be for you
this is a member of the canadian
parliament who was caught
naked naked on a virtual house of
commons meeting it's william
amos who's 46 and he represents the
quebec district of pontiac he has since
apologized in an email to his colleagues
saying he'd been changing into his work
clothes
after going for a jog quite why he did
that in front of a camera
who knows thankfully he had his phone
with him in a very handy place
so that's all good now the scottish
traveler community is demanding an
apology from the scottish government
over claims of historical
mistreatment dating back to the 1940s
the tinker experiment saw families torn
apart
and placed in inadequate housing a
scheme supported by the uk government
and scottish local authorities our
scotland correspondent
james matthews reports they were the
subjects of the so-called
tinker experiment they call it eugenics
social engineering over decades that
separated families
and ruined lives i was born in an
experiment
and had no say anymore
in a clearing in a pursue forest is the
gypsy traveler community
seamus mcphee was born into 50 years ago
then it was one location of many for the
tinker experiment
primitive hearts seen here after they
were occupied
built to encourage gypsy travelers away
from a nomadic existence
and towards settle society but all
executed
with sinister intent according to shims
to demolish and eradicate gypsy culture
and to affect a form of cultural
genocide
and it was part of a punitive series of
measures
and you know a drive against offseason
purges against gypsy travelers
with a view to making them conform
the tinker experiment led to some
families being broken up
if a family outgrew the accommodation it
was given
children could be taken into care the
damage is done
it won't be repaired teresa was one of
those children
even before she and her twin brother
were born they were earmarked for
removal from the family home
her brother died in middle age an
alcoholic
teresa blames a lifelong trauma rooted
in his childhood experience
it had a terrible impact on his life
he's the one that suffered the most
because he couldn't cope with it
there were several thousand people
involved in the so-called tinker
experiments
which lasted over many years in recent
years
those involved have sought a formal
apology from the scottish government
which hasn't been forthcoming a
spokesperson said
we accept the lives of many gypsy
travelers have been blighted by
historical policies and practices
of councils and charities and we
absolutely recognize the devastating
and lasting impact this had we must now
focus on working together
to deliver the actions to address the
inequality and injustice
that this community continues to face
it's a government's stated intention to
get things right
if not the apology sought for an
experiment gone wrong
james matthews sky news in perthshire
well this is sky news breakfast let's
check in on the weather for you this
morning
with kirsty good morning what have we
got today
good morning steven we've got some
sunshine today very welcome sunshine it
feels quite warm
in the strong sunshine this time of year
but some rather chilly nights so still
frost
to watch out for if you're a keen
gardener
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning high pressure dominating
our weather over the next few days so
for most of us that means some
fine dry and settled weather but it is
rather chilly
at night so a widespread frost this
morning but temperatures will start to
recover fairly quickly in that strong
sunshine it is dry just about everywhere
the exception will be across parts of
east anglia essex and kent
where we've got that northeasterly wind
driving in a few
showers here so eastern england later
down towards parts of the southeast
we'll start to see a few more
showers as the day goes on with that
brisk northeasterly wind pushing them in
so it's cooler and cloudier with the
potential for a few showers here but
elsewhere
feeling quite pleasant in the sunshine
in the afternoon with light winds
temperatures peaking around 13 or 14 in
the shelter spots across western
scotland
through the night tonight it's going to
be another chilly one though with
another widespread frost
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
kirsty thank you still to come on sky
news breakfast we'll hear from
hospitality uk about how pubs and
restaurants have fed
so far since their outdoor reopening
in england
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
mandatory evacuation i'm greg milam
sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles it is almost
impossible to predict
where these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
philly no go away look like it sir
you need to leave but you're not
understanding
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis i've seen
heartbreaking
human stories christ church
has been changed forever by what
happened here
[Music]
[Music]
now more than hundred and twelve
thousand people affected by brain tumors
have signed a petition calling on the
government to fund
research to help find a cure the hope is
to bring funding to the same level
as breast cancer and leukemia well let's
talk to eddie adams who was diagnosed
with a brain tumor
in 2017. look it's good to see you this
morning
i mean this must have been devastating
news at the time
just how did this come about how did you
find out what was going
on so
um i i was living in brighton at the
time
um and i had a seizure one day all of a
sudden
and got rushed into hospital they did a
ct scan
and they told me that i had a brain
tumor and so what happened there what
happens in terms of treatment after that
so the treatments um can be quite
invasive as you can probably tell
um i had unfortunately complications
which most people don't have but
essentially what they do
is they um strap you down to a
like an operating table um
they cut open a hole in your skull and
then they wake you back
up to uh operate on your brain because
they need to know when they're
touching the wrong bits and when they're
cutting out the tumor
they can go a bit too far for example
and
so they need to hear you speaking in
order to
understand which part of the brain
they're touching
um then um it was
about uh i don't know 12 weeks of
radiation i think
hemazolomide which is an oral um
chemotherapy uh i actually decided
not to do that uh purely because
i'm i've always been a bit more
concerned about the quality of life
rather than the quantity
and uh you know the team of zola team of
zolomon does make you quite sick
um so i figured uh to help with it
so where does that leave you in terms of
prognosis then
um well there's about
i'm quite an optimistic person and i'll
find a silver lining
in most things but there is about 12
chance that i won't be here uh this time
next year
oh heck look what is
stunning and frightening in all of this
is is when you look at the figures that
brain tumors kill more
children and adults under the age of 40
than any other cancer
but they get only about one percent of
the national spend on cancer research
that absolutely astounds me
i genuinely think it is a national
scandal that it's been going on this
long um
you know one one percent uh is uh
not a great deal especially considering
it is one of the most
uh deadly forms of cancer that there is
um and you know the treatment i had was
the same treatment that you would have
had 20 years ago to be honest with you
um and you know unless the uh
government decides to uh have parity of
funding it's going to be another 20
years
before they uh start getting other
treatment options
i mean a bit a big issue with this also
has to be
awareness as well because we know i mean
the the breast cancer
campaigns that have been held that have
had such publicity and understandably so
has created a huge increase in in
funding and donations i mean
i guess just just you talking about this
could actually begin to make a
difference
uh well i hope so i mean you know i
think
uh it is an important um
uh you know again it's the it's the
parity of funding that really
is the most important thing i you know
awareness is
fine but uh you know the research needs
to be done
and it needs to be funded properly yeah
look how do you stay
so optimistic i mean you're you're a
young man you're only in
sort of early 30s aren't you i've got no
idea
um you know uh yeah i'm i'm 32 now
living with my mother and a hole in my
head um it is difficult to be optimistic
and i'm often not optimistic but uh you
know you can present that way
yeah so what what about the down times
then i mean what
what level of support do you get there
are there organizations and charities
that are there to assist people with
brain tumors
there are uh macmillan are really
fantastic
um and uh you know actually with the um
brain tumor research charity um uh
which i found uh you know really
we didn't even know a great deal about
it until we spoke to
started speaking to the brain tumor
research uh
charity and uh they're fantastic um and
they've done this report um that is
going to be sent to parliament today
um i'd urge all of the people um
who are watching this to contact their
local mp
and say that you support uh this uh
funding uh a parity uh parity of funding
sorry
and um uh you want to see something
happen
yeah well look you put forward a very
strong case uh eddie
keep smiling when you can
i will do darling okay you be good take
care thank you
thank you bye
do you know it it's it's heartbreaking
isn't it and with 32
32 i'm 47 and so 32 to me seems
very young but honestly
it takes you back now new figures
suggest pubs restaurants and bars which
were able to reopen in england on monday
so levels of sales double compared to
before the coronavirus pandemic well
this time last same time last year so
we're sort of technically in lockdown i
think at that stage but
research from the cga food and drink
insight show
light for light drink sales jump by
113.8 percent
on the first day of outdoor trading
compared with the same day
in 2019 so let's talk to the chief
executive of uk hospitality kate nichols
good morning i mean you must be pleased
with the figures
we're very pleased it's it's a signal of
a positive start that people are keen to
come back out
socialize with family and friends in a
safe environment
there are a couple of notes of caution
to these figures however this is just
one day's trading
for a start and it only relates to those
premises that were able to open so
two thirds of our premises didn't open
on monday and won't be opening until may
so this is just for the cohort that were
able to open their doors
and obviously even then even these
positive figures it's a psychological
and a positive opening but it's not an
economic one
because for those figures to be as they
are they're still only generating 20
of their normal revenue so well below
break even
but it is a good signal that people will
come back and the consumer pent up
demand
is there yeah i mean i was going to say
i mean comparing it like for like for
the same day when we were in
in lockdown last year it does sort of
distort those figures somewhat doesn't
it
um look how difficult is it
obviously as you said so many venues are
still closed
but does this offer some level of sort
of hope a bit of light at the end of the
tunnel for those venues that
that they can at least start to see a
reasonable return
when things open for them next month
i think that's the main sign of hope
that we get from these figures
the concern had been that after being
locked down for best part of five months
effectively
that consumer demand was not going to be
there that consumer confidence was not
going to be there to come back out to
venues
when people have been at home for such a
long period of time but what we have
seen is that our message of reassurance
that these venues are safe
and it's a safe place to socialize has
got through and that people
are keen to come back out so that gives
us hope for the future
but it's still going to be a long road
for recovery for many of these
businesses to build up
and until we ease those social
distancing restrictions on the 21st of
june
these businesses will be open but not
trading at a profit so it's really keen
that the government confirms the roadmap
now
and confirms that it's going to move
ahead and end social distancing
restrictions on the 21st of june
and yet we've had new research uh out
today
spoke to dr julian tang behind some of
this new research in the bmj
saying there's actually much more
concern now about
um airborne transmission of covid19
rather than transmission by touch now
that raises very serious implications
for pubs and restaurants to reopen and
to have people inside without
those limited numbers for perhaps quite
some time to come
well this is one of the areas that we
have worked on over the course of the
last year and it's included in our
protocols for reopening
and now thankfully it's included also in
government guidance
we've always worked really hard on
maintaining that ventilation is a key
mitigating risk against
kovid legally restaurants and kitchens
are required to meet building standards
of good ventilation
our guidance and best practice that came
out last year talks about throwing open
doors and windows in smaller venues
that don't have a mechanical ventilation
standards
so we can make sure that ventilation is
good in our premises
that we are well ventilated that reduces
the risk even further
and so we've already been addressing
this for the last year
and government guidance as i say now it
also includes it so it's a it's a
a measure that our ventilation standards
actually are higher in many kitchens and
restaurants
than they are in hospital hospitals and
education settings
look there's been some concern voiced in
some of the newspapers today actually
from from theater venues and saying that
they
fear with the looking forward to
reopening but with
the limited capacity they're going to
have
it could still all be basically head
towards closure
i mean that is still going i mean that
presumably that threat applies to
to hospitality as well that you know
this isn't now a
um an open door to success for
a lot of your venues uh absolutely not
and and we have the same issues that
uh theaters live music venues cinemas
all have
we can be open but we're not open
economically and we know from last year
with all the social distancing
restrictions the capacity caps
the one meter plus distancing the
restriction on the number of visitors
the best we were doing last year for one
week was to break even
most of our venues are trading at a loss
at sixty percent of normal revenue
so until we find a way of moving past
that social distancing restrictions
and allowing these businesses to open
freely they will be making a loss and
that
it'll be a long uh shadow that covid
casts the industry will have economic
long coded
over it for a long period of time which
may yet mean that many more venues are
failing many more businesses fail and
jobs will be lost until we can get
through that period get social
distancing lifted as planned and as
promised by government on the 21st of
june
okay good to talk to you thank you
now still to come on sky news breakfast
i'm going to be talking to the shadow
minister for domestic violence and
safeguarding jess phillips about a
series
of portraits to commemorate women killed
by
men in the uk
i'm siobhan robbins sky's southeast asia
correspondent in bangkok
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
the enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
we saw snatched us going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
you either live and recover or you die
[Music]
okay so that's like a walk that's the
war yeah
we help you understand the world with us
the past 24 hours the soldiers have been
attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we've been crushed we take you to the
heart of stories
that shape our world they were convinced
the united states would become hooked
they were right
we hear shotguns being fired and also
tear gas is being
put around the information on this could
bring down the entire network
not just in iraq and syria but across
the world
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
the safety rage podcast for the ones who
want to know more welcome to the all out
politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we make
small changes to our lives
we can reduce air pollution by loads but
how much
exactly loads
hello there for many it's a chilly start
this morning but dry with long spouts of
sunshine to come
and fairly light winds as well there
will be a scattering of showers in a
brisk northeasterly across parts of east
anglia and southeast england
but otherwise temperatures peaking at
around 12 or 13
celsius now we're expecting low levels
of air pollution across the uk and
ireland through thursday as these
cool conditions persist the showers in
the southeast also keeping the levels
low little change expected as we head
into the weekend so low levels of air
pollution
across the board the air quality report
sponsored by philips air purifiers
now over the last year in the uk 118
women and girls were killed by
men it is a figure that is so shocking
the mp jess phillips read out the name
of every victim in the house
of commons on international women's day
last month
now one illustrator has responded by
creating portraits of
every victim to remember them and make
their stories visible
and de brady reports kelly fitzgibbons
was one
of 118 women killed by a man over the
course of 12 months
in the uk she was shot dead by her
partner
who also killed their two little girls
ava who was four
and lexi who was two their three lives
were erased in a matter of seconds
i met kelly and her twin sister emma at
the youth club just there when we were
all 13.
sue redmond was kelly's best friend and
often comes to this memorial bench where
they first met as school girls
in bosom in west sussex to think about
her
it's so important purely because it's
it's raised our awareness
we had no idea until someone gave us the
heads up that
kelly's name had been read out in the
house of commons we had absolutely no
idea of the number of women
i i wouldn't even have thought there
were that many murders in the uk per
year let alone
women murdered at the hands of men it's
just truly shocking and
and it's very very right what just
phillips has done
in this place on international women's
day labour mp jess phillips read out in
parliament the names of
all the women killed by men over the
course of a year
in britain kelly fitzgibbons
killed alongside her two daughters
artist tenny beaumont saw that speech
and decided to paint a portrait
of every single woman i was obviously
hugely saddened but i was also really
shocked that
actually the only name i recognized at
that point was sarah everard
um and actually she wasn't on the list
yet but she did mention her name
um and it just made me think you know it
made me
curious in a way about who all these
other women were and why we didn't know
them
kelly's twin sister has set up a
charitable foundation in her name
to provide support and legal advice to
families whose loved ones die
in traumatic circumstances henny says
the aim of her work
is to remember honor and make all
these women visible enda brady sky news
well jess phillips joins us now good to
see you this morning
um how important is it
that these women and their lives
are being not only commemorated but but
you know really really
brought to the the forefront of of our
consciousness once again
it's really important to me um i think
as a policymaker
it's very very difficult to try and get
across the enormity of some of the
things that we have to do
um in politics and in westminster and
we forget often that lines on paper and
big numbers
um that are read out uh on the news and
we forget the what we're talking about
when we talk about politics
is we're talking about people the people
in our country
and for somebody who focuses on domestic
abuse the sheer numbers
of people murdered of uh victims in this
country of children living in domestic
abuse situations often those big numbers
mean that people find it very
difficult to actually comprehend um and
so
breaking it down and hearing from people
like kelly's family
and and the pictures that henny has been
doing
they give they breathe life into
something
that people need to realize was people's
lives
yeah i mean look i mean we talk i have
to talk
numbers every day and and you almost get
used to it
don't you which is horrific in a way and
i find it difficult when we
have to talk to the relatives of victims
or people who've passed away and it is
as you say all about this thing that
these are people with lives and
histories and families
yeah and i think that that's sometimes
that's the most maddening thing about
politics
is that you'll sit opposite um
and i'm sure that the opposition would
say the same about me uh you say
opposite people and
and you're desperately trying to get
them to see
your constituents or see these
particular cases
um and and the reality is is that the
business of government
often dehumanizes people um but i spend
every day i mean
kelly's sister actually kelly from that
piece that you just showed
she's a resident in birmingham she lives
very near me
and i've spoken to her family on the
telephone i spend my time speaking to
the families of
these women and many of the women who've
been killed
since i read that list whose names i'll
have to read next year
their families get in touch with me and
each and every one
honestly thinks that their case is like
an isolated case that
this doesn't happen to other people and
until we
make those connections and get the you
know the government to
to really take that up and understand
that this is these aren't
isolated incidents this is a pattern
that we have to do something about
then i'm afraid i'm going to keep on
reading out many many names
well look i mean i i thought it was
really interesting that in
ender's report there you know kelly's
best friend from school
obviously knew what happened to her
friend and to her friend's two daughters
when you read out 118 names was
astounded
she was astounded she thought there
weren't even that many murders
in the uk in a year never mind just of
of murders of
of women by men
yeah and i think that that's the reality
and i think in the light of the sarah
everard
case where i i i believe that some of
the terminology to try and
understandably make people feel at ease
they said oh you know it's about it's
punishingly rare that this thing happens
but in reality a woman is murdered at
the hands of men every three days in the
united kingdom
and i'm afraid to say that at the moment
it's uh women killed by men is at its
highest rate since 2006 and has been
rising every year
so this is the problem that is getting
worse um and
the the reality uh of the situation for
uh lots of victims of domestic violence
is that
the threat of murder the threat that
somebody will kill you if you try and
escape if you
speak up if you do anything or say
anything that is a pattern that we see
not just in 119 cases i'm afraid that
pattern is
being perpetrated across the country
today in
up to nearly a million homes so how
important is it then for
i mean not only to raise public
awareness of what is going on by
what you've done and what henny is doing
with her artwork
but also to for those women who are in
these very difficult situations to know
that they are not alone i mean i know
it's a grim outlook for them in some
respects
to see people who've died but but to
know that they're not alone they're not
absolutely isolated in what they're
going through
it's the most important thing that we
actually do in uh
anyone with a platform anyone uh on the
media anyone in politics anyone
to speak about this issue when women at
home now are right now listening to this
and feeling that their life is
represented and it might
not it might not be that they feel
that today is the day that they can
break away but every single day my inbox
and today will be no different we'll
fill up with people saying thank you
because
that is what my life is like this is
what i have to put up with and
making those women realize that there is
help that they are not alone that then
the things that their abuser is telling
them that they're wrong that no one will
listen that they won't be believed
they'll be
deported that those things that we as a
state we
we will try and do everything to sweep
in and help that woman
now the trouble is is that as a society
still
and i'm afraid to say that the domestic
abuse bill is today
and uh we will be putting to the
government some of the things that we
wish to see
changed is that for too many women who
come forward
still there is not a good enough
response because there isn't enough
resource in the system
so that's the issue we've got to fight
jess phillips it's really good to talk
to you this morning thank you
and look if you are affected by any of
the issues that jess was talking about
you want to speak to someone
you are not alone you can call the
domestic national domestic abuse
helpline 24 hours a day
seven days a week their number is 0808
2000 247 0808
2000 247
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
you